I am recently married because most
comics die alone weeping softly into a
cracked mirror and so I am a beacon of
hope and that's why it is exciting and
I've been doing stand-up comedy forever
forever since women comics would get
stage time right before they were burned
as a witch back in the 1600s I opened
for Hester Prynne should have tied five
in the Iroquois it was great and I
married a man huh I like to tell people
cuz you know who thinks I'm gay
almost everyone could've been went to
college it's not like I might not know I
met my husband doing online dating I
love online dating because it's a
flippant drop-down menu option I'm a
woman looking for a man to date tapping
a tap tapping to tap you exchanged some
emails you dash off to a Starbucks you
look at each other for the first time
and then one of you goes no no no I have
to and you go home and you do it again
and again and again until you meet
someone who isn't horrified by her
initial appearance it's really just that
romantic and my husband makes video
games for a living yeah yeah I know I
was like how did you get that job and he
says it's perfectly obvious I got that
job I fought my way through several
levels and then I killed the boss yes
and I recommend I tell people go out
with a guy who plays video games go the
guy who collects action figures and
reads comic books go out with that guy
marry that guy cuz that guy's home right
now he's been a curio shop he's got to
organize his action figures it keeps
them off the pipe it keeps them off the
pole it's nice but he's a game designer
right so he'll play any game that you
want to play Paper Scissors rock card
games board games video games dress up
like an elf go away for the weekend
dudes dipped more than once when we were
organizing our wedding he referred to
our outfits as costumes he wanted us to
dress as pirates and take over another
wedding I am NOT saying that that would
not have been fun I am saying I am NOT
organizing to weddings crazy man and
he's like why would we have to organize
a second one arm and then we went on our
honeymoon and he wanted us to get
matching tattoos and I'm not tattoo
people I don't want to tattoo I said
instead of tattoos why don't we do what
old people do in Wisconsin where I'm
from when they travel which is collect
those spoons and he said oh my god let's
get tattoos of those spoons we'll each
get a cabinet tattooed on our backs and
then everywhere that we travel we'll get
it if we're spoons Exeter
for the rest of our lives and I was like
wow I would rather get a plate in my
head and collect magnets Rhode Island
and I lived here we live here in Los
Angeles and before I go into a dilemma
to make an announcement I love animals
we all have animals people are animals
LF people when I was a kid in Wisconsin
if you had an old dog or a very sick cat
you would sadly very sadly put the dog
down put the cat to sleep and that dog
or cat would go to happy dog or cat
heaven and you would go to the pound to
get a new dog and it was the circle of
life and it was very beautiful and that
isn't happening in crazy Los Angeles
land where people are like oh no the
cats only 17 we're gonna get dialysis
are ya I have a friend of mine who has a
cat that's 21 21 years old and in
addition to the plethora of other
problems that this cat has like it
cannot move it now has diabetes and so
she has to shoot it up twice a day you
know what that is time for a new cat you
can't 20 sedae why do you get a cat so
you don't have to do anything that's why
you get a cat because it poops in a box
and you can go to work
$3,000 for diabetic cat medicine for
this cat you know what that is 3,000 new
cats
the people get mad at me and they come
up to me they say you don't like animals
no I don't like you you're a jackass
about your pet you get 15 20 years
that's all you get I didn't make that
rule if you would like more than that
please do not get a cat or a dog turtle
turtle turtle tiny turtle hat too too
carried around you're creepy
Paris Hilton purse for like 30 years it
could lift its head up adorkable giant
tortoise that can walk slowly around
your backyard for 300 years and become a
burden on your descendants where I go to
eat breakfast here in Los Angeles right
next to my breakfast place there's an
animal eye care clinic just don't care
just for the animals I don't have
insurance
let's get mittens some contacts better
now or now better now or now that joke
is adorable thanks a lot you guys
[Applause]